la oea limpia su nombre su director
general Rafael Cruz insiste en el que el
organismo de control nuclear no tiene
autoridad para impedir que Japón vierta
al océano agua procedente de la central
nuclear de fukushima que sufrió un grave
incidente en 2011 pero se muestra
tranquilizador Y promete que se llevarán
a cabo controles frecuentes
no aprobamos el plan ni recomendamos que
se aplique estamos diciendo que el plan
cumple las normas Así que creo que este
calificativo es importante porque a
menudo se dice que es unilateral no
estamos tomando partido no estoy de
parte de Japón ni de China ni de Corea
las normas se aplican a todos por igual
en Corea del Sur donde Rafael grossi
está de visita el viernes las
autoridades insisten en que las
consecuencias para el país serán
insignificantes pero la población dista
mucho de estar tranquila como sus
dirigentes en este picado de pescado de
seúl la gente ya está preocupada por el
impacto de las ventas
estamos haciendo menos ventas en parte
porque es verano pero también porque
ahora es mucho más difícil hacer ventas
porque los clientes hacen más preguntas
sobre la radiación están muy preocupadas
llevamos realizando pruebas de radiación
desde 2014 por aquel entonces se
realizaban tres veces por semana pero
ahora las hemos aumentado de 3 a 5 veces
porque los clientes están muy
preocupados por el vertido de las aguas
residuales de su cochino
una vez tratadas y diluidas se espera
que Japón vierta al océano más de 1,3
millones de toneladas de agua
contaminada esta astronómica cantidad de
agua se almacena actualmente en la
central de fukushima que está llegando a
su punto de saturación